[Applaus]
haben immer die anderen
diese leidvolle perspektive
multipliziert sich natürlich wenn wir
uns nicht hin zu verschönen und
superreichen vergleichen
unüberbrückbar hohe sich selbst über
optimierten menschen zeigt sich seit
heute in cannes die filmfestspiele sind
angerollt wir waren einen tag vor der
prominenz da und es hat sich gezeigt
dass frauen leben an der côte d'azur
gleich dieses jahr einem
spießrutenlaufen werk anfang an kämpfen
winkel an der forex gilt das gebot der
guten laune sich selbst ein kränzchen
winden ist hier ausdrücklich erwünscht
das gute miene zum teuren spiel am
besten 24 stunden lang schöner leben und
angeben bei tag und bei nacht so
modellen ist ganz oder war was zumindest
mal
in diesem jahr ist manches anders die 70
jahr feier steht ganz im zeichen der
sicherheit also diese stadt fertig jeder
winkel wird überwacht jeder besucher als
bedrohung in betracht gezogen
auch wir fühlen uns chronisch beobachtet
so sehr dass wir im polizeihauptquartier
nachfragen sicherheitschefs barros
bestätigt unseren verdacht big brother
entgeht nichts
um an der content gefilmt zu werden muss
man kein star sein was die kameras
betrifft verfügen wir wie sie sehen
können über das dichteste netz
frankreich in der gemeinde haben wir 550
überwachungskameras das macht 140
einwohner programm durch dieses dichte
netz ist die sicherheit in ganz gern
gewährleistet allein entlang der k 6
sind 28 kamera zum einsatz
das 24 stunden pro tag platziert an den
sensibelsten orten im raketen beschossen
wird
der terrorakt von nizza im vergangenen
juli hat tiefe spuren hinterlassen
weil der lastwagen attacke herrscht an
den uferpromenaden sid frankreich
erhöhte alarmbereitschaft
im film festival meckert kann sowieso
was da geschehen ist hat doch geprägt
und wir haben daraus unsere schlüsse
gezogen und das sicherheitsdispositiv im
vergleich zu früher noch weiter
totale überwachung und kontrolle als
hoher preis wie ein bisschen mehr
sicherheit
die kameras der polizei sind zwar nicht
versteckt aber man muss schon sehr genau
hinsehen um sie zu entdecken
sogar ein stammgast donath keusch den
wir hier vor dem festival palais treffen
zeigt sich überrascht als wir ihm mit
einer kamera konfrontieren
dabei kennt sich hier kaum jemand besser
aus als der meinungsstarke schweizer
filmproduzent wir seit 40 jahren nach
cannes zu reisen fliegt
die kleine aber die leute fehlen stand
der extreme geschäft läuft das programm
bot nicht um wettbewerb
alles bloß sicherheitschecks
die festivalleitung widerspricht behält
apropos liga total ist dass wir dass
sich die leute geschützt doch nicht
bedrängt der ganze sicherheitsapparats
unsichtbar bleiben
es war tresor per view schöne neue
festival welt zum glück karten hat kein
rezept gegen den kontroll und
überwachungseinheit ins lokal ein
rustikales restaurant abseits der
prozess fern neugieriger objektive
[Musik]
ermöglichen christin wortmenue bietet so
alles bringen ist mit einbringen audi
zeigt wie viel das ist klassisch um 180
grad kalte wasser und ein zivi und das
ausnahme ist der mini all4 euro
inbegriffen
diesen preis bezahlt
schließlich ist gerade in cannes kaum
etwas kostbarer als ein stück vom einen
guten leben
[Musik]